il est à peine six heures le soleil se
pointe le bout du nez et déjà certains
noms peuvent plus d'attendre on s'est
levé à minuit quand il est venu c'est à
deux autres matin de vaudreuil pour
avoir la chance d'être jose
en fils à 2 heures du matin vicky et son
conjoint n'était même pas les premiers
arrivés chez eux 00h30 installé devant
la porte du bureau de service canada
corentin a bon espoir de mettre la main
sur son passeport aujourd'hui il part
pour la france demain ma grand mère
allait pas bien en début de mois puis ma
mère est partie la rejoindre dès que ça
devançant peary malheureusement est
décédé entre-temps
ce qui fait que les funérailles sont ce
week-end et j'aimerai toujours ya être
honnêtement pour de nombreuses personnes
ici ce sont plus que des vacances qui
sont en jeu sonia entreprend une
carrière de camionneuse dans quelques
jours elle vient ici je recommençais sur
la route ça plein passe pas parce que je
fais du états unis longue distance
j'essaie d'obtenir un passeport pour
mama petit soit il ya sept mois
si on veut aller voir la famille de mon
conjoint en france la raison de ce
cafouillage évoquée par la ministre
chargée de service canada devant le
comité des ressources humaines aux
communes est une explosion des demandes
de renouvellement de passeport puisque
les gens ne voyaient j'ai peint et ne
faisait pas de demande de passeport en
fait en 2010 9 2 millions 300 mille
passeports ont été délivrés puis en 2000
vingt premières années de la pandémie ce
nombre a chuté à 360 milles en 2021 il
était d'un million deux cent mille alors
que cette année service canada prévoit
en émettre jusqu'à quatre millions trois
cent mille on a deux questions qu'on
pose maintenant avant même de commencer
à y vendre c est vous vexer bien pouvoir
passe pas
dans cette agence de voyages ils sont
témoins de la reprise du tourisme
international les gens ne préfériez les
ponts avec
selon le titulaire de la chaire de
tourisme transat cet engouement était
somme toute prévisible trois fois plus
de québécois qui veulent faire un voyage
hors canada que l'an dernier alors ça
explique pourquoi on se lance dans les
demandes de passeport et la demande est
très grande
à l'ouverture des portes à 8h30 ils sont
maintenant près de 250 dans la file
d'attenté c'est ce que ça peut être plus
lent mais de là à être comme celle
sommes maintenant c'est
incroyable
service canada a embauché 600 nouveaux
employés et promet d'embaucher 600
autres faut-il aller plus loin ou encore
allonger les heures d'ouverture des
bureaux de passeport
parce qu obtenir le précieux document
semble maintenant relever de l'exploit
ici sébastien desrosiers radio canada
mon rêve